but cocaine Cowboys one and two oh my
god it's that there was one year where
everyone who graduated from the police
academy either was murdered or went to
jail every single graduate was either
killed because their they had a part a
part of the cocaine business or they
went to jail for being corrupt Wow all
of them there's more a pattern of this
is true please Google this there there
were at least at the time more banks per
capita in Miami
than anywhere else in the country
because it was all used to launder
cocaine money Wow
yeah no [ __ ] man again man you get
that level of money and as you start
getting banks and stuff I'm just saying
those two men documentaries I can't say
enough good things about them they're so
good sounds exhausting not the
documentaries but the actual business of
doing it well that's why you need coke
coke on your own supply man that's the
only way to keep up with the young kids
I mean if you Rick Ross which one the
real one or the real one no no the
rapper Freeway Ricky no yeah yeah the
real Rick Ross I know I know is the
freeway Ricky yeah that's the one you
want to ask you don't to ask the rapper
the rapper was a prison guard
do you know yes yes well you know
Freeway Ricky who's been on the show a
couple times sued to get his name back
and to keep his dude from using his name
because he was actually Rick Ross that's
his actual funny story I didn't know
he's on your show dude he's been on
twice Rick Ross Freeway Ricky was the
guy who was selling all the cocaine that
paid for the Contras when the Contras
are fighting the Sandinistas in
Nicaragua in that hole Oliver North [ __ ]
chorus Freeway Ricky was the one who was
selling all the coke to these people he
didn't know how he's getting these coke
he didn't know he was actually getting
out of people that were deep deep state
deep state but I'm telling you I'm
telling you to find the threshold he
learned how to read it's a great style
Ricky learned how to read in jail and
then learned how to become a lawyer in
jail and then realize they tried him for
they did they hit him with three strikes
but they hit him with two charges at the
same time which is not how three strikes
work so he went to jail for life and
then got released for time for time
served because they tried him
incorrectly right so yeah rikes was in
exactly one of his strike they were
there at the same time you can't do that
it has to be like you go to jail you
come out you go to jail again you come
out and go to jail again they go alright
you're a criminal
I'm gonna keep you in jail that was a
height idea which is [ __ ] up
what's it like sitting across the table
from you he's a very nice guy very smart
guy he was a tennis player man played
tennis in Compton
yeah couldn't [ __ ] read man couldn't
read played tennis in Compton and was
just seeing all these people around him
that were making crazy amounts of money
Wow and is a real calm nice guy and
that's one of the reasons why he did so
well said he wasn't this crazy buck wild
dude driving Rolls Royces throwing money
out the window he wasn't that guy he was
like the cool calm collected John wick
sort of character that kept his [ __ ]
together you know and everybody
respected him because of that he just
was like you mean the same reason why he
learned how to be a lawyer while he's in
prison
he's a systematic you know intelligent
dude who just had a [ __ ] education you
know just grew up in a very bad scary
dangerous environment and you know
didn't even learn to read and in jail in
Lincoln the history of the Irish it and
I had it was selling coke and didn't
even know who he was selling it for
didn't know that the people he was
selling it for like the the context that
he had were directly supplied by the
Oliver North Bush and yeah Wow
interesting man
yeah Matt Wow I just have all over north
for president t-shirt I wore it just to
piss people off I didn't know what it
meant I was like 17 the whole thing's
crazy that this Rick Ross guy the rapper
was actually a prison guard there's a
photo of him was [ __ ] prison guard
uniform on Wow
I mean I liked him a lot I reckon Ross
the way I do I liked it and that was a
lie on with the big st. I don't know the
big single I don't
I do have one big one that I've sang
before